un calme relatif de retour au darfour
après trois jours de combats intensifs
et meurtrier
si la paix semble précaire grâce
notamment à l'intervention des troupes
soudanaises
l'onu ne veut pas attendre une nouvelle
escalade de violence
après près de 13 ans de présence la
mission de l'onu a annoncé son retrait
en décembre dernier une décision déjà
contesté par les habitants
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas de paix
totale et globale au soudan et c'est
pourquoi nous refusons le départ de la
mission de la minuad pour que la mission
de la minuad parts
il doit y avoir une paix totale et
entière pour tout le peuple soudanais
désarmer les djandjawid est jugé toute
personne ayant commis un crime au soudan
selon un communiqué du comité central
des médecins soudanais les affrontements
du week-end dernier ont fait près de 200
morts
malgré des accords de paix signés entre
le gouvernement de transition et
plusieurs groupes rebelles en octobre
dernier
la situation reste particulièrement
tendu c'est cette situation que le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu va étudier
dès aujourd'hui depuis 17 ans le conflit
au darfour a fait près de 300000 morts
et plus de deux millions et demi de
déplacés